good morning everyone we are about to
hear a non-germaine Amendment on Senate
bill 19. this was handed out to everyone
previously but it's not right in front
of you at the moment so I've asked Karen
to whip off copies again in but we're
just going to hold off until you all
have hot off the press another copy of
that
while I have the committee members here
I just want to let you know that we
representative Almy brought to my
attention that last week on the consent
calendar a bill was passed that will
come to us as a second committee Senate
Bill 49 thank you for pointing that out
to me so we will meet probably next
Tuesday I hope everyone can be here for
that so we can hear that bill it has to
do with the oplc dedicated fund we had a
similar Bill already in the house so
we're gonna need to take a look at that
and see what we think so plan on next
week we don't know what else might be
it's coming to us as a second committee
that's why we voted on it in the house
last Thursday
[Music]
yeah we already passed it on consent
calendar from another committee yeah we
sorry for the delay thank you and
welcome uh without further Ado we will
now open up the public hearing on
2023-1606h to Senate bill 19.
and the chair recognizes representative
almi to introduce this amendment thank
you thank you madam chair
on
this is a pretty simple amendment to a
bill which is meant to make it on easier
for existing bingo games to continue to
exist
and this one on
has the same goal all it does is to say
change the 25 dollars per game date that
Charities May
um
provide for expenses to their
volunteers since Bingo is total has to
be totally run by volunteers
and it changes it from twenty five
dollars to fifty dollars because this
hasn't been changed in a long time and
there's been a lot of inflation and if
somebody has to is
traveling from a distance
um doesn't have time to feed themselves
unless they buy food once they get there
on
apparently sometimes buying pins and
things on the
they they only get reimbursed up to 25
and the
um original sponsor of this amendment
which was given to us
by Senator Rosenwald in the hearing
uh
is
Senator Susie but the we've checked with
the Senate and senator avard who is the
main sponsor
of the bill did send from wherever he's
been traveling did send an okay
so
um
I hope that we can pass well I think
we've already got two amendments
planned for this bill and we can pass I
hope we can pass this one too when we
get to the next step after after the
caucuses thank you would you be open to
answering questions sure any questions
from the members you guys have seen this
we've talked about this a little bit but
we we felt like we needed to schedule
this hearing yes representative Doucet
thank you madam chair I'm just curious
with uh representative Spielberg and I
are trying to find out I thought I had
seen this in a in a house bill
addressing the increase from 25 to 50.
am I incorrect in that or are we
collectively I don't I don't think that
was about bingo I think that was charity
games okay okay thank you
I I would just like to say something it
seems to me that we are regulating Bingo
and putting constraints on them a lot
more than we're doing it on on hugely
representative Southworth
thank you I just wanted to clarify you
said uh it had been 25 for a long time I
assume that really it's been a very long
time and this is almost housekeeping as
far as updating the regulation
possibly I mean it's like 20 years I
don't remember doing it but that doesn't
mean anything
representative fellows
um yes
um do you recall that um one of the
comments made by Senator
Rosenwald was one example that she gave
had to do with like somebody needing a
babysitter before they could volunteer
and so when you think about what a
babysitter might cost I know you're not
going to get very far with 25 I don't
think
yes uh other questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you and we have a pink card from Rhonda
sorry about that my name is Rhonda Lane
I'm consultant for the Wolverine Youth
Football Association in Derry I've been
involved with Bingo for 21 years
my concern about raising the 25 to the
I believe they should get paid and there
are current rules on the books for to
allow them to get paid they just have to
apply for their consultant license
I have mine I have others that work
under me that have theirs and that's how
I'm able to pay them
the environment around Bingo
um
is suspect and unfortunately it gives
Bingo a bad reputation
there are a number of bingos currently
that pay their volunteers cash
and it could be fifty dollars seventy
dollars upwards to two hundred dollars
from my own personal knowledge
and I just believe address bringing this
up to fifty dollars now you're talking
about
a workable wage where there's no taxes
on this money
and on top of that I don't believe the
current behavior and environment is
I just think it's just going to make
less profits for the Charities
as I I believe all of you received an
email from me last week
addressing the 16 days I just think it
allows the Bad actors to conduct this
type of behavior
in this type of environment we want run
a very successful Bingo the Wolverines I
believe we are always in the top three
in the state of New Hampshire we do it
with complete transparency we have a
staff we have people wanting to come
volunteer for us so with the 25 isn't a
problem
um I think adding to that on top of what
is being made out with these cash
payments
there needs to be more accuracy and
accountability through the lottery as
well and I believe they're working on
that to get the forms
so that there's more exposure to what's
actually being done Bingo is an all-cash
business
so it does lend itself to Bad actors
unfortunately and in the end result the
players aren't getting their money and
would you be open to questions from the
committee absolutely okay I'm going to
start here and go around the room
representative fellows
um thank you for sharing some of that
information because
um I don't believe there are any bingo
games around where I live in I have no
exposure to them at all
but part of my question is
do you understand that the bill just
allows people allows organizations to go
up to 50 and they don't have to go up to
50 if they don't want to
but I believe and I feel
that
if you're a bad actor you're going to
grab more nights
and It ultimately is going to limit the
pool of Charities that can conduct Bingo
and want to conducted
I'm going to keep going around the room
and we can Circle back if we need to
other questions on this side seeing none
representative Elber
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um one of the things to be aware of in
this uh proposed amendment is that these
are to reimburse for expenses and there
has to be a
the expenses must be submitted this is
not pay
it's specifically to reimburse expenses
well a charity would have a record of
those
right I will tell you it is my
experience that
I don't know where you get fifty dollars
in expenses between gas and meals
um
I don't believe throughout the hall that
I'm currently in
there is one volunteer that has child
care
I'm not saying it's not possible but I
oh thank you
I wonder though if maybe some of the
folks who do have children don't
volunteer because they don't have child
care and this might allow them to do
that I can only tell you that has not
been my experience thank you thank you
madam yes you're welcome um ores did you
also have a question yeah thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question so your concern is
a more legitimate charity that's run
properly like yours is going to suffer
as a result of this I
well I certainly with the 16 days I
think it's easy for any bad actor or any
hall manager to that also holds a
consultant license which that can be
addressed down the road
um
they take control of the hall
and they'll kick Charities out to
we've just had such an experience
to get control of those nights
in the 16 days just opens that up to the
Bad actors hands down
100 confident that that's what's going
follow-up so is this very pervasive
throughout the the whole Bingo industry
you think or I can tell you I came in 21
years ago as a treasurer of the
organization
and
just stepping in the operator that we
had I was looking at the books
she was embezzling
and that was my first initial
welcoming to bingo
um I've seen things over the years
there was a perfect storm that has been
recently
formed since November
that brought a lot of information to
light
um
with what is actually being done behind
the scenes with
some organizations that I'm aware of
follow up to the follow-up no we're
going to move on and we're going to stay
okay and with all due respect I do want
to make sure we're focusing on this bill
and the wording excuse me of this
amendment and the wording of this
amendment we do have to be very careful
about suggesting that people are guilty
of things in this forum just get in
general okay thank you representative
Doucet
yeah in just a long thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question have you filed these concerns
or aired these concerns with Lottery yes
I have okay where do where do you folks
hold your mango dates Community Bingo
Center currently we are in
the process of moving our last game data
Community Bingo will be
okay we're gonna go around the room
representative Lloyd
um just a quick question so I work in
non-profit Finance
um and I know that with expenses uh
being reimbursed out to volunteers we
usually ask for some sort of paper trail
do you know with the organizations that
you're working with is there a set
process for paper trail and requiring
actual printed receipts or I can only
tell you for myself I have a log when
they sign in and they'll check off meal
gas that kind of thing there's no
receipts
they're just signing that they're
getting the 25 reimbursement for those
expenses
representative
yes please explain I'm here oh I'm sorry
please explain you said you were a
consultant and therefore you can get
paid is that what I heard you said yes
the rules within Lottery allow for
a consultant to get paid for their
services okay and in turn I have
subcontractors under me
that they receive their Consulting
license and they're allowed to get paid
and how do you become a consultant
what's it take you 100 fee fill out an
that's it
okay we're going to keep going around
representative fellas did you have
something else
um yes so there's a distinction between
the Consultants who are essentially
employees and I assume that they
they have a W-4 and income taxes yes and
all of that yes and then there are
there's a different category of people
who are volunteers
and
I I wonder in terms of
just this amendment I mean I think I
think that we want to still allow
volunteers to receive some reimbursement
for their role I don't know I don't know
I don't know if you have a lot of
volunteers on in the games that you work
with or not but do you think that it's a
good idea to
delete the itemized expenditure because
what I'm hearing is that people are not
doing that anyway
this this bill says it reimburses them
um yeah I'm not quite sure what the
motivation was for that wording but so
well just what do you think of the idea
is so the current law says they can get
reimbursed up to 25 and they have to
submit an itemized expenditure to you
know say how much
um
it doesn't say receipts but itemized at
least what they're asking for and but
this amendment says they can get up to
fifty dollars now and they do not need
to submit an itemized list of
expenditures do you have a position on
that well I found that that being
striked was questionable I didn't know
why it would be but
um I'm opposed to the 50 because they
certainly even the volunteers can get
paid just
put aside the 50 do you think that
alumni eliminating the need to itemize
identify the expenditures that they're
being reimbursed for it's important or
or just assume do away with that
I would think it's a you know you have
gas you have your meal
um outside of that if if there's a rare
occurrence where you have child care
certainly that could be checked off on
your sign-in sheet or whatever
um
thank you so much other questions from
the committee thank you so much oh
representative elberger
thank you madam chair
um
I'm not sure what a big old consultant
does could you just
what is it we don't know I don't know
what a consultant in a bingo setup would
do we're there we're organizing the
volunteers we're ordering the supplies
where
coordinating the structure of the games
we do internal controls we do the
accounting we do the marketing we it's a
full-time job
it is a full-time job and then there's
people under us that we have doing
certain activities whether it's counting
tickets or taking control of the
Facebook pages and the postings and
um
I I think the illusion of bingo
sometimes as you walk in you sit down
you play Bingo and everybody leaves
there's hours countless hours behind the
scenes making Bingo the particularly our
Bingo the success it is
um
okay thank you you're welcome
representative okay please do not take
this question as argumentative I just
want to understand
you were arguing against raising from 25
to 50 but you're pushing Consultants
will get paid I don't understand the
logic well I think once you get to the
50 threshold you're talking about an
hourly wage
and all of this money continues to go
untaxed including the cash payments with
the consultant if if you feel the need
to pay that individual more money for
the services that they're providing
now you're you're coming into the
representative Janine
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I guess I'm a little
confused when you say it goes untaxed
because they should only be reimbursed
for the expenses so it's a reimbursement
for expense not a wage that should be
taxed exactly but my my
issue and it has been for a very long
time are these cash payments that are
being made on in addition to
many of these Charities have never taken
the opportunity to write the 25
reimbursement checks it was a running
joke when the investigators would come
in and say Rhonda you're the only one in
the state that's doing it well I we have
transparency we you know we have
exposure
um
so now that they're advocating
that this be pushed up to fifty dollars
it's questionable because I don't
believe the cash payments are going to
follow up uh so just so I understand
um Charities have the ability to pay
Beyond this reimbursement they can pay
someone yes if they have a hold of
Consulting license okay so if they pay
them then the charity also has to issue
a 1099 correct so how are they not
paying taxes if they get the 1099 I mean
that would be no this is for the
volunteers if they're labeled a
volunteer and they don't have a
Consulting license okay so if the
charity pays a volunteer
that's what you're saying then don't
they give the volunteer 10.99 no
representative self-worth
I thank you partly question for the
chair I mean I think these are very
important points and obviously because
this the Bingo issue comes to us often I
do think they need to be addressed
through the lottery they really don't
have anything to do with the amendment
so
um I just see dividing it in half but I
do feel and I guess it would be through
you that we perhaps should follow up on
the lottery on some of the regulations
on Bingo for example are people supposed
to have checks or not that's really not
in our area but I think it's an
important question to answer
the rsas do state that all Bingo
expenses are to be issued with a
thank you very much you're welcome okay
I don't have any more also oh uh sorry
hi yeah
um so I I just want to make sure that
we're clear on this um because I do both
accounts payable and payroll in
non-profit Finance
um so generally when you have payments
made out to someone
um whether it's a volunteer or whatever
once they meet that 600 threshold in
earnings at that point they get issued a
1099 statement and then that gets
recorded and reported to the federal
um the federal government for their
income taxes expense reimbursements
would only be for reimbursing
out-of-pocket costs paid by volunteers
and those should be backed up by
documentation that's presented to
whatever group is paying these out so
these would be like you know if they
went to uh to go get pens for something
they would have a receipt for those pens
and they would they should be
you know easily documented so I don't
know I don't know if we're confusing
some of those terminologies
um or or not but as soon as an employer
or as soon as I volunteer makes over six
hundred dollars it should be recorded on
a 1099 and reported right but they're
making over 600 most of these bingos
have double two sessions a week
um
the the cash is not being recorded
anywhere
could be more of a dra issue actually
than
so well it's a lottery issue just just
your follow-up on that question what
tell me explain who is getting the money
that's not being recorded and in your
experience the volunteers I've seen it
I've seen it firsthand
okay thank you
yeah
the volunteer gets the money the cash
yes well no a check no cash
no you just said that every
reimbursement has to be paid by correct
but what's happening in the industry
right now is they're getting cash fifty
dollars seventy dollars up to two
hundred dollars and I'm saying that
raising the stipend from 25 to 50 is not
I do not believe it's going to change
that culture or that behavior
well that's an Enforcement issue yes
beyond the let beyond the scope of this
legislation again I just I'd like to
remind everyone folks here we're just
trying not to be accusatory of other
folks we certainly welcome other
people's opinion and how this would
affect you but I'm a little concerned
about yeah I'm just telling you my
observations what I have seen
okay thank you uh other final questions
no thank you so much for coming today
okay are there any more uh Pink cards on
Senate Bill 19 Amendment 1606.
representative Ames would it be
um
could we ask the lottery directly to
come up and talk about
uh
sorry I I my question is to the chair
and whether we might ask the lottery
director to come up and uh share with us
how the lottery addresses the review
of uh the
reports on expenses by bingo organs that
Mr director and
um Chief enforcement officer would you
mind coming up and enlightening us thank
you
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee Charlie McIntyre and Hampshire
Lottery with me is Valerie King director
enforcement so she'll be answering this
foreign
so the specific question I'm assuming is
how do we ensure that they're paying
their volunteers correctly
so it is a cash business so that can be
difficult for us to regulate we do rely
heavily on them reporting correctly they
are supposed to be paying by check
um any of the volunteer reimbursed any
expenses are supposed to be paid by
check
um
I'm not sure what other questions you
are you open to further questions yes
representative Platt if they're paying
by cash how would you know
it would be similar to any business that
took cash in and cash out we'd have to
see it and encourage or somebody would
have to sort of submit it a verified
complaint with the basis of knowledge uh
and suggest to us that they saw X and Y
and then we'd have to investigate that's
there's a number of bingo halls and
there's only so many investigators and
they're also involved in other
facilities investigations so
I will tell you this representative the
most difficult part of our job is where
cash and people are together
yeah can I just just a clarifying
question and you as you guys know I
wasn't involved in this industry a
little bit
um isn't it up to the charity to decide
it's the charity deciding is it worth it
for them to reimburse these volunteers
or not it's up to them to decide right
if it's in their best financial interest
or not am I right or am I totally wrong
yeah they're not required to pay
reimbursement it's only a reimbursement
can be paid for actual expenses up to
okay all right representative Leafly
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so just to verify
this is all laid out in RSA
bingo halls are supposed to report
um the money they take in I imagine the
money that goes to the charity and then
of the money the charity receives it
would be up to them
to write a check to a volunteer
um
whether
the charity does do does a charity have
to report separately
or is the bingo hall reporting
everything that came in
so it's the charity that's required to
do all the reporting the the commercial
Halls are only providing the space the
equipment they're not actually running
the games the charity runs the games
okay so when the charity
um fills out their paperwork to explain
how much money came in how much money
they made would
would there be a line for this or would
this just come out of you know they made
ten thousand dollars it's their ten
thousand dollars and if they choose to
you know spend it this way or that way
they don't need to report that to you
or is the volunteer part like a line
that gets reported to you it is a line
that gets reported okay thank you that
helps me understand
other questions
representative elberger I saw her hand
floating away and floating is the right
way to put it thank you madam chair
having been both a volunteer and an
employee
I am very confused about what seems to
be a combination or
putting those words into meaning the
same thing if I'm a volunteer I assume I
do not get paid
if I'm a volunteer and getting
reimbursed for expenses that's not pay
and I don't understand why it would need
to be reported at all if I submit
something saying I spent so much for gas
I spent so much on a babysitter whatever
the expenses might be but there would be
no reason to have to report that and am
I mistaken here
as far as reporting the reimbursements
it's more so that we can track profit
the overall how much is the charity
making so they have to report all their
expenses and subtract their expenses to
come up with their profit
of follow-up so
the volunteer who is getting reimbursed
doesn't need to do any reporting but the
charity needs to keep that information
and it's the Charity's responsibility to
do that
correct correct and they they report it
to us I'm not talking about any IRS I'm
just talking about reporting to us thank
you thank you madam chair okay other
hands up representative Southworth thank
you The Corner Spot
um two questions I think you've hit on
them a little bit so basically it's up
to the charity more than the person
whether they cross the 600 threshold
really both it should be but from your
right but yes it's up to the charity to
be letting us know how much their
expenses are and reimbursement is one of
the expenses but the key part is it's
not really your responsibility that's
the Charities like an employer and it's
their responsibility and with cash that
of course is going to be tricky but my
other question I want to get back to the
amendment because that's really why
we're here
um can you just remind me
um it seemed like you didn't see a risk
when we were talking before about
raising it from 25 to 50. so I just want
to clarify that because that was my
sense that there really isn't a big risk
um we don't have any objection to it
being raised uh it's mostly that they're
reporting it correctly and that's our
bigger hurdle is is the actual reporting
representative Phyllis thank you madam
chair
so
um
I wonder if you can share with us what
kind of oversight you have of the uh the
these charitable bingo games
um how how often
um is it particular charity
inspected by by your organization and
when they do get an inspection or an
audit I don't know if they look at the
books what are they looking at and
so we currently have I think we have
Three Investigators and they cover both
our Bingo and Lucky Seven which can be
outside of a bingo hall as well as our
games of chance they do rotate around
they'll check in on the Bingos various
bingos going on they can't be there all
the time and they're looking for things
that are visible at the time so you
trying to find out if someone is lying
on the paperwork it's not something
they're necessarily going to see when
they're doing an inspection
oh
so does that mean your your organization
is never looking at the accounting
that's done by these Charities so that
they could identify you know how how
much in is being paid to volunteers or
or the consultants and therefore there
are no like receipts to ask to look at
that kind of thing we do conduct conduct
occasional
um uh audits a handful each year there
are quite a few Charities so we're not
touching all Charities every year they
will look at the paperwork but again in
a cash business it can be hard if the
paperwork is missing or has been altered
it may not be easy to detect that
there's an issue
just just
yeah so
when you say a handful of
audits of the paperwork each year and
you're talking about
I don't know however many 60
um Bingo charity groups and then you've
is this also in this pool is the gaming
gambling charity gambling is in that
same pool of the so
um Auditors usually go when they do
inspections they usually go for the the
where where there are the most
expenditures they don't offer audit the
little tiny companies you know so is
that also the case
um I mean obviously these are Charities
so we're not you know coming in as if
there's IRS audit we're there to help
not you know be adversarial and we do
have a risk management process where the
larger amounts of money are looked at
okay thank you very much
all right I don't have any more pink
cards anyone else would like to speak
any other suggestions from the committee
seeing none we will close the public
hearing on Amendment 1606. okay we will
break and uh the Republicans will caucus
upstairs and we'll come back uh for
around 10 o'clock to see what we can
expect today thank you very much
um oh representative only point of order
well you you can stay here yeah
it's fine with me yeah
um and obviously uh we 10 o'clock might
be tight now I wasn't expecting that
amendment to take so much uh time so um
I can't do anything about that yet but
we'll we'll plan on being closer to 10
15. yeah on this Billet we just heard
what is the timeline on this does this
have a deadline or uh well we'd like to
try to get this exec today if possible
and remember Senate Bill 19 has the core
Bill and then this is one of the
amendments there are two other
amendments we'd like to try to get it
done today it is on the calendar today
we don't have to
uh okay because I'm what I'm thinking of
is along the lines of maybe taking the
Cross out on this amendment that takes
out the need for itemized receipts maybe
that shouldn't be eliminated in just
straightforward why don't you discuss
that with your caucus and see what you
guys want to do on that um and then
we'll come back and see where we're at
so could we if if we were if we go down
that path do so we could not exec on
that one today that would be I would
prefer to exec today if possible but
let's talk about it and see see we'll be
doing some struts some stropples so we
can move it along because it does seem
like when we come back that you can
quickly find out where people are at
well you know in a normal executive
session
um each person would you know move their
Amendment and we see if it goes forward
or not and then then we know right at
that point okay all right let's break
thank you
all right do we have everyone here
wait
um
okay I apologize about the delay looks
like everyone here is here uh
representative all me is there someone
coming in for representative Smith
okay
so everyone's here if we could just go
around the room real quick and uh
substitutes just say hi tell us who you
can you please use the microphone so we
Andy renzullo thank you for joining us
and moving along
Alvin C
thank you for joining us no other
substitutes over here yes
Crystal Lloyd thank you for joining us
and Doug Thomas thank you for being here
okay with that we will now open up the
executive session on Senate Bill 19 and
the chair recognizes representative
pletts for motion
yes I moved ought to pass with amendment
all right we first need an ought to pass
and is there a second for a
representative for ought to pass
representative Southworth seconds okay
and the bill is open to Amendment
representative Platt moves Amendment
1475. yes would you like to speak to
your Amendment
Amendment 1475 simply allows uh 16 days
of Lucky Seven to coincide with the 16
days of bingo that the underlying Bill
allows
and I have to have two amendments
because it's in two different places of
the law which means the law should be
recodified eventually
is there a second on
1475. second Madam chair
representative Schoenberg seconds
okay is there discussion on that
Amendment
seeing none the clerk will call the role
on Amendment 1475 to Senate Bill 19 and
for the record I am involved in the
thank you madam chair representative
genegian
yes representative ulery
represent Ducette yes represent
spilsbury yes representative plant votes
yes representative C
yes representative Thomas yes represent
orrs yes representative brazilo yes
represent army yes representative Ames
yes represents Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Schomburg yes representative fellows yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
yes representative liply yes
uh and the chair yes because 19 to zero
one not present
okay the bill is now open to further
Amendment the chair recognizes
representative Fletch hold on one second
I dig out another sheet
yes I moved the amendment of uh
amendment number 1603 which does the
same thing as 1475 just in a slightly
uh that Amendment 1603 is seconded by
representative Ami uh
would you like to speak further about
that or any other comments
okay other companies represent all me
I'd just like to say you don't have to
put them in two different amendments
that's
uh it's only for deciding whether
something's non-germaine I I did it that
way only because I did
1475 and then I got to point it out to
me it's a different place on the law so
to put in another amendment you're right
if if I had been perfectly aware in
advance I would have done it one
Amendment
this is how we learn any other comments
over on on uh 1603
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
okay representative janigian yes
representative ulery yes representative
yes representative spilsbury yes
representative yes representative SC yes
representative Thomas yes representative
orrs yes representative renzullo yes
representative Almy yes represent Ames
yes representative self-worth
yes representative Malloy yes
yes representative Schaumburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Lloyd yes represent
elberger yes a representative leapley
yes
and uh the chair
yes 19
01 100 uh when the voter 19-0 the
amendment passes and the bill is now
open to further Amendment chair
recognizes representative only
thank you madam chair I move Amendment
1606 to SB 19 FN
is there a second
representative elberger seconds would
you like to speak to your motion
and this is a pretty simple amendment
that simplifies a bit the uh law on how
Charities are allowed to compensate
their own volunteers uh and increase
doubles the amount of money they are
allowed to compensate them
because there hasn't been an increase in
a long time and it's harder to get
other comments on Amendment 1606 from
the committee
I'm seeing none the clerk will call the
roll
representative genegian
yes representative uluri yes
representative yes represents Pillsbury
yes representative plant votes yes
representative C yes represent Thomas
yes representative orrs yes represento
yes represent all me yes represent Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
uh Schomburg yes representative fellows
yes representative Lloyd yes represent
alberger yes representative lippley yes
and the chair yes
19 to zero with one not present
okay the vote being 19 is zero with
Amendment 1606 passes so now are there
any further amendments on Senate bill
19.
okay seeing none now the motion is that
we're voting on is ought to pass as
amended
by 1475 1603 and 1606 when the clerk is
ready we will take the rule the clerk
unbelievable
sorry is there an ought to pass as
amended uh sponsoring co-sponsor
uh I I representative plant uh did it
for onto passes amended with the First
Amendment yes
um representative plett would you like
to be the blurb writer I guess is the
question okay he'll be the verb writer
uh but if someone else wants to help him
with that that'd be great
okay on I'll second okay and as uh
okay all set uh representative janigian
yes represent uluri yes representative
descent yes represents Pillsbury yes
representative plant votes yes
representative C yes representative sodi
uh Thomas yes representative orrs yes
representative renzullo yes represent me
yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes purpose of
Malloy yes representative Schoenberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Lloyd yes represent
elberger yes representative liply yes
representative Smith that's gonna be uh
absent and so the chair
yes okay 19 zero and one not present
is there any objection to putting this
on the consent calendar if the clerk
allows it
and we will now close the public hearing
uh excuse me the exact session on Senate
foreign
we will now open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 20 relative to
Keno license applications and fees and
the chair recognizes representative orrs
uh thank you madam chair
I make a motion to accept
sb20 reducing the fees for Keno
licensing as an ought to pass motion as
an opt to pass motion thing is there a
second second representative elberger
seconds
uh thank you madam chair I think the
reducing the fees for Enterprises to get
involved in Keno licensings gives more
people the opportunity I think the
current fee is five hundred dollars it
is rather High I think this will give
more opportunity for operations to be
involved and in enhancing revenue for
the State of New Hampshire thank you
other comments from the committee
representative fellows
um yes I don't support this bill because
I I don't think any business who
thinks they will profit by having Keno
wouldn't can can afford the 500 fee and
if you eliminate that fee and it does
proliferate which I'm not sure that you
really pick up
too many more you might pick up more
businesses but there will be low volume
that that just spreads the cost
spreads the need for inspection over a
wider array of businesses and that could
be an additional expenditure for the
lottery so I I don't you know I don't
see any big financial gain to the state
for doing so so I'm opposed to this
representative Ames did you want to say
anything
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
roll oh sorry representative thank you
thank you madam chair just for clarity
the the way I understood the testimony
with the Advent of uh convenience stores
and the like uh offering Keno where they
were having to pay out Keno tickets and
not getting the advantage of selling
Keno this addresses directly an extra
five hundred dollars that those vendors
would have to pay in the periphery of
that it eliminates the fees for uh
people that pour alcohol and serve serve
food but in the fact it's uh it's this
piece here is taking away uh the fact
that President Keno licensees presence
sorry Lottery licensees can now sell
Kino and will not incur the extra 500
fee
other comments from the committee
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
thank you madam chair this is on Senate
Bill 20. uh represent janigian yes
representative ulery yes representative
Doucette yes representative yes
representative
representative C yes representative
Thomas yes representative orrs yes
representative renzullo yes
representative army yes represent Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Lloyd yes
represent elberger yes representative
liply yes
and the chair yes
eighteen one and one not present
the vote being 18 to 1 ought to pass
motion passes uh I believe with one
person uh opposed to the majority report
it can go on consent uh your reports
you're putting it on okay so without
objection we will request to go on
consent
and we will now close the executive
we will now open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 120 relative to
charitable gaming license applications
wages stakes and bonds and for the
record I am involved in this industry
the chair recognizes representative
Spielberg
I move
OTP and will offer an amendment
on SB 120. is there a second for the
ought to pass motion
representative Doucet seconds
okay uh and uh would you like to you
have an amendment did you say
yes
so I think everyone understands that SB
120 largely parallels hb607 passed by
this committee and out of the house the
amendment number is the amendment number
is one five seven seven h
so the the bill
is largely making changes to definitions
technical uh enforcement related changes
changing some license fees but the
amendment focuses specifically
on section 14.
which is uh on page eight and nine of
the bill the amendment itself couldn't
be simpler it simply says delete section
14.
so what's section 14 would do
is it would eliminate from current law
specific instances of violations
segregated into three categories by
degree and those are defined as minor
moderate and major
simply leaves this language in current
law
the reason for the amendment is twofold
number one as I had pointed out when we
had our executive session on hb607 I
think it is a big step backwards to
remove specific instances of violations
which show degree and even though the
commission is allowed to find other
instances because the language says this
is
not limited to at least it allows them
to have
something that they can set at a
commensurate level
so it does a disservice to the current
law to eliminate these the other reason
why it would have to be amended anyway
is because
unlike hb607 which addressed minor
moderate and major violations this bill
addresses only minor and moderate and is
silent on Majors so it only did
two-thirds of the job
so anyway I think we should all be
perfectly content with the statute the
way it is and the way that the
commission has been interpreting it
their rulemaking is currently well
founded there's no reason to change this
part of the law so please support the
amendment
1577. oh representative Phillips yeah I
would just like to say that
um with
that I support the amendment because
without it the it makes the situation
about trying to decide you know what
kind of violations going on way too
other comments from the committee seeing
none the clerk will call the role on
ought to pass on Amendment 1577 on SB
120.
representation yes representative ullery
yes representative Doucet yes
representative spilsbury yes
representative platforms yes uh
representative C yes representative
Thomas yes represent orrs yes
representative renzullo yes
representative army yes represent Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Schoenberg yes representative fellows
yes representative Lloyd yes represent
elberger yes representative liply yes
that's 19 to zero with one not present
really a moment
okay um so the motion before us is uh
ought to pass as amended
by 1577 on Senate bill 120. uh
do I need representative spilsbury do
you want to make that final motion I
guess
I move out TPA on uh SB 120. I second
that moment okay
representative Schamberg
okay the motion before sun is that ought
to pass is amended by representative
spilsbury seconded by representative
Southward uh Schamberg and uh is there
any further discussion on that yes
said earlier
House Bill 607
did I have the right number
um which was passed by this committee
and then passed by the house and sent to
the Senate where
it resides somewhere
and
um
it uh is not entirely the same as as
this bill 607 is not entirely the same
as SP 120 but it's similar and has many
of the same details in it but one detail
um is uh the uh a change in the amount
of a single wager by a player in any
game of chance
Uh current law
sets they shall not exceed
for such single Wagers of ten dollars
and this bill
would change that to fifty dollars going
from ten to fifty dollars for a single
wager 607 House Bill 607 the bill that
we passed
did change this provision but moved it
from ten dollars to twenty five dollars
I think moving to fifty dollars is uh is
too big a leap for me to swallow I I
accepted the 25 but did it uh heightens
the risk for players of course they can
make a choice to wage at lower levels uh
assuming the Halls were there uh they're
playing uh or gaming
allows lower wages but uh
um they uh are really unrestricted in
their ability to go to the higher level
which is five times the current level
and I think it's it's more risk than I
can accept so for that reason as it
stands I uh I intend to vote against
this bill
other comments from the committee
representative almi
thank you one
material difference between two material
differences between this and 607 which
is in the poison maidens Committee of
the Senate and they've been holding on
to it to see what we're going to do I
believe
um is
the theft by deception which I think was
a good catch uh and the moratorium which
on this committee has agreed to go along
with the Senate version of
so if we turn this bill down they would
have to amend
there's
ours the way they want to and and send
it back for concurrence or not
and
I agree with my colleague that going up
to fifty dollars from 10 all at once is
pretty much of a leap without trying the
intermediate step thank you
other comments from the committee
representative Doucet
thank you madam chair I just uh add into
this being the prime sponsor of 607 and
that limit being 25
I went into that knowing and and into
digging into that what we have for a
model in charitable gaming the the
normal player goes in there at least
from what I understand and there are two
dollar five dollar player
this targets a different demographic of
people that may go down to Encore and
may capture those folks to stay in the
charitable gaming halls in New Hampshire
I'm not necessarily opposed to a 50 bet
limit but to make the assumption that
all of a sudden a two dollar play is
going to stop betting fifty dollars is
is just that presumptive and I don't
think we're gonna see
you know proliferation of that uh I've
been in these rooms spend some time in
in structuring and writing 607 and and I
think I know I don't think it's going to
have a Major Impact it's going to allow
to broaden the appeal to some people who
are bigger Gamers uh than normally as
seen in the uh
charitable gaming rooms in the state but
I don't see a a big problem with 25 to
50 either
other comments from the community
representative Phyllis
um yes just along the same line of 25
versus 50 for the increase one of the
things that we heard from testimony is
that there were concerns that the
Charities might not have on hand enough
money available to pay out the winnings
if if things just you know went you know
in one one you know some sometimes there
are big Winners sometimes there are not
and we heard that for as a concern for
607 when we were talking about 25
dollars so that's just another concern
just to clarify because I do remember uh
that bill but they were referring to I
believe it was Lucky Seven
just under a whole different set of
statutes not this
yeah I'm looking over there so he's he's
the he's the author of 607 so he would
know that that's the testimony I
remember Madam chair was about the Lucky
Sevens and nothing left
okay other comments on the ought to pass
as amended
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
did we vote on the amendment I lost
track I Apologize yes it was 19-0 on the
amendment so now we're doing the final
final which was moved by representative
spilsbury and representative Schamberg
so ought to pass on Senate 120 as
amended by 1577 h
yes representative janigian yes
representative ulery yes representative
set yes representative Pillsbury yes
representative plant votes yes
representative C yes representative
Thomas yes represent orrs yes
representative
renzullo yes represent all me no
representative Ames no
representative Southworth no
representative Malloy now
representative Schoenberg no
representative fellows no reps is Lloyd
no
representative liply now
representative the chair
yes
the vote is 11 to 8 with one not present
the vote being eleven to eight uh the
ought to pass is amended motion carries
and this will go on the regular calendar
um and uh in terms of the majority
report Representatives spilsbury
we'll do the majority report
uh and The Minority Report who will do
that
representative Ames okay
okay with uh that is the close of the
okay
before we open up Senate Bill 189 uh do
people have an amendment in front of
them hopefully everyone has a copy of
amendment 1628
good
good okay
okay we will now open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 189 relative to
the definition of growth business taxes
no gross business profits and
determining taxable business profits
for the record I pay business profits
tax
chair recognizes representative janigan
thank you madam chair I move uh ought to
pass on SB 189. is there a second second
oh I'm sorry representative
representative Olney seconds
uh the bill is open to Amendment the
chair recognizes representative Olney
thank you madam chair on this amendment
was oh do you want to move it first I
want to move Amendment 1628 to SB 189 FN
is there a second
representative elberger sentences okay
please speak to your Amendment
thank you the amendment was offered by
the group that was defending
um this bill from Global business
Alliance on and
it it was done with
um the idea that some of us are really
worried about the revenues for next year
and
uh the year after and having no idea
that nobody except the business
concerned has any idea how much Capital
uh investment on companies that we get
taxes from are going to be making this
year uh
we
won't know whether that would add
substantially or not at all to our
revenue losses next year if the other
things that are hitting us all all hit
in the worst way at the same time so
what this amendment does is it can on
extends in the same way that the tax
cuts and jobs act did but on just a
little modified so that it only covers
three years it it takes the we've had
three years already in which we have
been on
taking
a thirty percent thirty percent and
thirty percent and 10 percent at the end
of the capital investment interest
income as a deduction interest payments
is a deduction and
on what we are going back to is what we
had three years ago which was that they
took the whole thing as a deduction in
the same year and we've been doing that
for a very long time and the tax cuts
and jobs act uh changed that because we
did not decouple
a lot of other states have decoupled
and um we
on what so what this does is it says
we're decoupling
from this and but on for the next three
years a third of the cumulative on carry
forwards from these three years that
we've been doing it thirty percent
thirty percent thirty percent ten on a
third will
be taken every year on top of whatever
on interest
deduction you're taking
for this past year
so I hope I'm explaining that clearly
enough on so that we will only be
responsible each year for the next three
years for the current Year's
introduction plus a third of the carry
forwards from the years before
on and then after the three years we'll
be back to where we were
seven years ago
doing the same thing that we've always
done
representative has a comment thank you
madam chair so just I representative
Almy I just want to make sure I'm clear
of what you're saying so
I understand the one-third
for three years of
interest
expense that was not taken but
you're you're saying that for the tax
year 2024
any interest deduction that that a
company would have in 2024 that complete
amount can be deducted is that correct
yes okay thank you plus one-third of the
other comments from the committee on
Amendment 1628
seeing none the clerk will call the role
uh this is a Amendment 1628 h on Bill
189 uh representative genegian yes
representative ulery yes representative
Doucet yes representative Pillsbury yes
representative yes representative C
yes represents uh Thomas yes represent
orrs yes representative renzullo yes
representative Omni yes representative
Ames yes representative Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes reperto Schaumburg
yes representative fellows yes
representative Lloyd yes represent
elberger yes representative leapley yes
and the chair yes 19-0
-19 president okay the vote being 19-0
on Amendment 1628
ought to pass motion carries and now the
motion before us would be I believe
unless there's any other further
amendments ought to pass as amended the
chair recognizes representative janigan
I make a motion to
ought to pass as amended SB 189.
yeah we did it on the bill well we did
on the bill but we didn't do it as the
ought to pass as amended so that's what
we're doing again so it's moved by
representative janigan seconded by
representative all me
okay is there any more discussion
yes representative Schamberg thank you
uh I feel that investments in Capital
Equipment is essential to the growth
for New Hampshire businesses and
employment
uh
this bill shows the business community
that the state of New Hampshire is
business friendly in other ways than tax
rate reductions or elimination of entire
established Revenue sources
thank you madam chair
other comments
seeing none the clerk will call the rule
on the ought to pass as amended thank
you madam chair representative janigian
yes representative uluri yes
representative yes representative
spilsbury yes representative plant votes
yes representative C yes representative
Thomas yes representative orrs yes
representative renzullo yes
representative yes representative Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes representative
Schaumburg yes representative fellows
yes representative uh Lloyd yes
represent alberger yes representative
leapley yes
in the chair yes 19 to zero with one not
present
okay the vote being 19-0 uh autopath has
amended uh carries on Senate bill 189.
uh
is there any objections for this going
on the consent calendar if the clerk
yeah we I'm not sure because of the
fiscal note sometimes I do sometimes
they don't but we'll request it and if
they don't we'll be ready to speak to it
okay so we're done
yes uh the question was when will we
meet again and I think we're going to
meet next Tuesday
uh let's say 10 A.M
and we will do at a minimum Senate Bill
49 and see what else we can get done at
that point I don't and I don't know if
we'll have anything else to do at the
point so we'll see
about two other builds
for hearings no no no oh for executing
yeah
right so so plan on next Tuesday at 10
and we'll get done what we can get done
so thank you to our substitutes thank
you for our regular members for being
here we really appreciate your help
today and uh
we're done for lunch before lunch that's
although you guys have some work to do
we need uh committee reports yes
yeah normally we want you to do them
um today and if if you could that'd be
great
um
yeah by the end of the day that would be
great that'd be great okay yes
representative Thomas yes uh I'm sure
let's just like to say uh uh I
appreciate being here and I also
appreciate the fact that you now have
our past humor secretary from our own
committee here working for you and I'm
glad that you have it as your Clerk and
I'm doing just as a sucky job as I did
there
I'm sure the humor is still the same
laughs
okay thank you everyone appreciate your